In addition to studying false memory, psychologists also study forgetting and
memory loss. Now, forgetting and memory loss are suggestive and reconstructive
processes. Sometimes it's easy to think of our memory as an objective recorder.
When, in fact, we see that our memories are affected by how we distort, select,
or even bias memory of events. So forgetting is the weakening of memories over
time and I'm going to share a personal example of that with you next. When we
think about forgetting, we think about things we may have learned in school,
such as definitions, equations or formulas. But we can also forget personal
episodic memories. For example, my Dad died when I was only 14 years old. And
for sometime after that I had lots of memories of everyday activities, things
such as eating dinner, going for ice cream or even watching TV. However, one
day when I was about 16 years old I realized that I had forgotten what my dad
sounded like. Now in those days we didn't have video cameras or phones with
cameras on them so I had no film of my dad talking. When I remember this, I was
so angry and upset with myself. I was beside myself. I thought how could you
forget what your own father sounds like? What kind of a daughter am I if I
can't even remember what my dad sounded like? Now I have since learned not to
be so hard on myself for forgetting those things, because I hadn't been exposed
to it in such a long time. However, I do try to actively recall and remember
more memories so I don't lose those. Now as an example of just how subjective
memory can be. My brother and a friend of ours recently got together, who we
hadn't seen in 20 years. And we were talking about this time that we all went
down to this stream and we caught a carp. We brought it back to my mom. Each of
us had a different memory of what our mom said and did when she saw that fish.
So we can see just how individual and subjective our memories can be. Perhaps
you can talk to your parents or siblings, and see if you can come up with a
memory, and whether or not you all agree on that's what really happened.